dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr karo jonai fajir
yes you see it correctly this is a paper
on
paper the paper paper if you will and
today you will witness
some amazing works in the domain of
computer graphics
and physics simulations there is so much
progress in this area
for instance we can simulate honey
coiling
baking and melting
bouncy jelly and many related phenomena
and none of these techniques use any
machine learning
these are all good old-fashioned
handcrafted algorithms
and using these we can simulate
stretching and compression
to the point that muscle movement
simulations are possible
when attaching muscles to bones as we
move the character
the muscles move and contract accurately
what's more this work can even perform
muscle growth simulations
so are we done here did these ingenious
computer graphics researchers
max out physics simulation where there
is nothing else to do
oh no of course not look this footage is
from an earlier computer graphics paper
that simulates viscosity and melting
fluids
and what i would like you to look at
here is not what it does
but what it doesn't do it starts melting
these armadillos beautifully
however there is something that it
doesn't do
which is mixing the materials start
separate and remain separate can we
improve upon that
somehow well this new paper promises
that
and so much more that it truly makes my
head spin
for instance it can simulate
hyperelastic elastoplastic
viscous fracturing and multiphase
coupling behaviors
and most importantly all of these can be
simulated within the same
framework not one paper for each
behavior
one paper that can do all of these
that is absolutely insane so
what does all that mean well i say let's
see them all
right now through five super fun
experiments
experiment number one wet papers
as you see this technique handles the
ball of water
okay we've seen that before and what
else
well it handles the paper too okay
that's getting better but hold on to
your papers and look
it also handles the water's interaction
with the paper
now we're talking and careful with
holding on to that paper
because if you do it correctly this
might happen
as you see the arguments contained
within this paper really hold water
experiment number two fracturing
as you know most computer graphics
papers on physics simulation contain
creative simulations to destroying
armadillos in the most
spectacular fashion this work is of
course
no different yum experiment
number three this solution here we take
a glass of water
add some starch powder it starts piling
up
and then slowly starts to dissolve
and note that the water itself also
becomes stickier
during the process number four
dipping we first take a piece of biscuit
and dip it into the water note that the
coupling works correctly here
in other words the water now moves but
what is even better is that the biscuit
started absorbing some of that water
and now when we rip it apart
oh yes excellent and as a light
transport researcher by trade
i love watching the shape of biscuits
distorted here
due to the refraction of the water this
is
a beautiful demonstration of that
phenomenon
and number five the dog what kind of dog
you ask
well this virtual dog gets a big splash
of water
starts shaking it off and manages to get
rid
of most of it but only most of it
and it can do all of these using one
algorithm not one per each of these
beautiful phenomena
one technique that can perform all of
these
that is absolutely amazing but it does
not stop there
it can also simulate snow and it not
only does it well
but it does that swiftly how swiftly
it simulated this a bit faster than one
frame per second
the starch powder experiment was about
one minute per frame
and the slowest example was the dog
shaking off the ball of water
the main reason for this is that it
required near a quarter million
particles
of water and for hair and when the
algorithm computes these interactions
between them
it can only advance the time in very
small increments
it has to do this a hundred thousand
times for
each second of footage that you see here
based on how much computation there is
to do
that is really really fast and don't
forget that the first law of paper
says that research is a process do not
look at where we are
look at where we will be two more papers
down the line
and even now the generality of this
system is truly something to behold
congratulations to the authors on this
amazing paper
what a time to be alive so
if you wish to read a beautifully
written paper today
that does not dissolve in your hands i
highly recommend
this one this episode has been supported
by weights
and biases in this post they show you
how to use their tool
to perform distributed hyper parameter
optimization
at scale weights and biases provides
tools to track your experiments in your
deep learning projects
their system is designed to save you a
ton of time and money
and it is actively used in projects at
prestigious labs
such as open ai toyota research github
and more and the best part is that
weights and biases is free for all
individuals academics and open source
projects
it really is as good as it gets make
sure to visit them through wnb.com
papers or just click the link in the
video description
and you can get a free demo today our
thanks to weights and biases for their
long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i'll see you next time